lo que quiere hacer en este vídeo es
practicar la forma de reconocer puntos
máximos y mínimos y veremos tanto puntos
máximos y mínimos relativos como puntos
máximos y mínimos globales
esta es una pantalla de la sección
reconociendo máximos y mínimos en
gráficas de funciones de el portal de
khan academy y dice marca todos los
puntos mínimos locales en la gráfica de
abajo un punto mínimo local no tiene que
ser el punto más bajo de toda la gráfica
solamente tiene que ser el punto más
bajo de entre los puntos a su alrededor
por ejemplo este punto de aquí no es el
más bajo de toda la gráfica el punto más
bajo de toda la gráfica está por acá
pero es más bajo que los puntos a su
alrededor por eso es un punto mínimo
local o relativo este otro punto de aquí
también es un punto mínimo local o
relativo pues está más abajo que los
puntos a su alrededor y este punto de
aquí es el punto mínimo global o total
de toda la gráfica y también va a ser un
punto mínimo local
relativo nuevamente porque es el más
bajo de los puntos que se encuentran
alrededor de este y yo creo que estos
son todos los puntos mínimos locales que
tenemos aquí sólo tres comprobamos
respuesta es correcta hagamos otro
problema marca todos los puntos máximos
locales en la gráfica de abajo los
puntos máximos locales o relativos no
tienen que ser los puntos máximos de
toda la gráfica simplemente tiene que
ser el máximo de los puntos alrededor de
él hay varios puntos máximos aquí aquí
hay uno no es el máximo global de hecho
el máximo global o absoluto está aquí
pero es un valor mayor que los valores
que lo rodean podemos verlo como un pico
en esta montaña este punto de aquí
también es un máximo relativo o local
este punto de aquí es interesante porque
si vemos a la derecha de este punto es
mayor que los puntos que están a su
derecha pero si vemos a la izquierda
este al mismo valor en los puntos que
están a su izquierda así que yo no
consideraría a éste como un máximo
relativo o local quitamos esto revisemos
la respuesta y es correcta hagamos otro
problema abajo se grafica una función
con dominio menos 86 es el intervalo que
incluye a menos 8 este coche te indica
que vamos a incluir este menos 8 y
nuestra función está definida cuando x
es igual a menos 8 todo el camino hasta
cuando x es igual a 6 y tenemos definida
la función para cuando x es igual a 6
pues tenemos aquí de nuevo corchetes si
tuviéramos paréntesis significaría que
se llega a ese valor pero no se incluye
pero aquí estamos incluyendo menos 8 y 6
marca el punto máximo absoluto de la
gráfica y cuando hablamos de un máximo
absoluto o un mínimo absoluto solo vamos
a tener un valor para el valor máximo
absoluto y un valor mínimo para el
mínimo absoluto el máximo será el punto
más alto bueno aquí tenemos varios
puntos relativos máximos este es un
punto máximo relativo ese también será
un punto máximo relativo incluso este
también sería un valor máximo relativo
pero queremos saber el valor absoluto y
el máximo absoluto será el punto más
alto de toda la gráfica que es este
valor de aquí comprobamos respuestas y
es correcta